family now looking for a new place to
stay after this thanks for joining us at
noon i'm heather mills an early morning
fire a house fire in the southwest part
of the valley near grand canyon and
peace way bianca holman at the scene
where investigators right now are trying
to figure out what sparked sounds of an
explosion bianca
clark county fire officials tell us that
no injuries were reported from this
house fire that happened early this
morning a woman who escaped the flames
tells us that two of her cats didn't
make it dying from the fire
all the neighbors were moving their cars
and just getting out of the way and
i heard some things exploding i don't
know what it was robert hebert lives
across the street from this home and
could hear yelling outside his window
around 5 30 a.m the side of the house
was fully engulfed in flames and
spreading quickly to the attic the
location was on the outside of the house
in some way it looked like some
recreational
living space like patio furniture et
cetera the fire was contained and no
other homes were damaged a total of 35
people responded to this situation the
firemen you know cut the gates
you know and
man they did their job they're amazing i
was really really impressed obviously if
you're asleep and a fire starts whether
it starts inside or outside it's always
good to have fresh batteries in your
smoke detector and also it's good to
have
predefined exit drills so everybody
knows how to get out of the house and
where to meet
deputy fire chief touchstone also tells
us that october is a fire safety month
so it's a good reminder to go ahead and
change those batteries in your smoke
alarms and smoke detectors reporting
near fort apache and flamingo bianca
holman 8 news now